hallo mein Name ist willkommen meine
lieben Freunde herzlich willkommen heute
zu mittlerweile schon zehnten Episode
von lustige Schülerantworten in Tests
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
der ersten lustigen Schüler Antwort und
zwar wurde in einem Test gefragt warum
wird das Leitbild mit T und nicht mit D
geschrieben erkläre wie man auf die
richtige Schreibweise kommen kann
Duden
ich meine es ist richtig bei der
nächsten lustigen Schülerantworten
sollte man in einem Mathetest zeigen wo
sich C anhand einer gegebenen Funktion
formelgleichung auf einem Grafen
naheliegend äh dann ist
ich habe selber keine Ahnung das hier
war auf jeden Fall diese
funktionswellen die ich habe wirklich
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Ahnung
oder so hat der Schüler 10 gefunden und
zwar hier
ich meine das ist auch wieder richtig
was allerdings auf keinen Fall richtig
war war die Antwort auf diese Frage wie
alt war Ludwig van Beethoven bei seinem
ersten Konzert und der Schüler schreibt
einfach acht
es gibt keinen Anhaltspunkt warum das
richtig sein sollte und bei der nächsten
lustigen Schüler Antwort hat der Schüler
tatsächlich gar keine Antwort
geschrieben sondern einfach 10 Euro
Bestechungsgeld hingeschrieben
er sollte nämlich drei Wortarten nennen
die er bereits kennt ich weiß nicht mal
was eine Wortart ist
dass sowas wie Substantiv
oder konjunkt
IV nein der sollte ein Schüler
beantworten für was die Abkürzung usw
Punkt steht und jeder weiß dass USB für
und so weiter steht der Schüler dachte
allerdings dass das Ganze Amerika
bedeutet
Amerika wäre USA
nicht USB
und USB ist auch nicht Amerika sondern
es ist dieses komische Dinge zum
reinstecken wo man eine 50% Chance hat
aber immer als ich das jetzt immer
falsch rum rein gefragt
weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht was die
Aufgabenstellung war er hat allerdings
das Wort Demokratie also die Demokratie
auf Englisch komplett falsch geschrieben
und hat es Demokratie geschrieben
das ist ein Trottel
ich bin übrigens auch ein Trottel ich
habe mir drei Brillen bestellt und keine
ihr entscheidet jetzt ich habe mir drei
Sonnenbrillen bestellt und alle meine
Freunde sagen dass mir keine von denen
steht ich sehe das genauso ich finde ich
habe keinen sonnenbrillengesicht aber
ihr dürft jetzt entscheiden fangen wir
an mit der ersten stylischen
Sonnenbrille meine Damen und Herren es
ist eine schwarze elegante Brille mit
blau orange gefärbten Gläsern was halten
wir hier vorne Nummer zwei ist eines
späßige weiße Brille mit orangenen
Akzenten in der Innenseite die der Otto
Normal Mensch die ich allerdings treffe
nicht sieht denn die sind ja
logischerweise von innen was halten wir
hier vorne das hier ist Brille Nummer
drei meine sehr verehrten Germanys next
Topmodel Zuschauer was halten wir von
dieser späßigen Attraktion und hier
sehen Sie noch mal alle drei schnieken
Sonnenbrillen nebeneinander dargestellt
schreibt jetzt in die Kommentare 1 2
oder 3 oder gar keine wenn er denkt dass
man Quadrat Schädel keine Brillen stehen
genug Fash meine Damen und Herren wir
machen weiter mit der nächsten Lust igen
Schülerantworten und zwar dieser hier
woher bekamen die Männer in der
Altsteinzeit ihre Nahrung
Neymar geht zusammen in Wald gucken wo
Tier dann tot Tiere und Essen Tiere
genau
ist völlig richtig hier sollte ein
Drittklässler beantworten wie viele
Zentimeter in einen Meter passen und
jeder weiß dass 100 cm in 1 m passen
auch ein drittelblätter der ist 9 Jahre
alt der weiß das auch und bei der
Antwortmöglichkeit wurden sogar so drei
kleine Unterstriche gegeben so dass man
weiß dass die Zahl drei Ziffern haben
muss der Schüler antwortet allerdings so
viele wie man rein kriegt
so einen auf ja der Eine kriegt zehn
rein der andere kriegt 200 dran alter
Mann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke ein Biologie Schüler sollte die
zwei wichtigsten
Werkzeuge der Gentechnik benennen
und hat dort einfach Messer und Gabel
hingeschrieben
also ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt richtig
oder falsch
ich glaube jetzt nicht dass die zwei
wichtigsten Werkzeuge der gentechniken
verdammtes Messer und eine Gabel sind
bei der nächsten lustigen
Schülerantworten geht es um
Prozentrechnung
darum handelt allerdings der fail hier
nicht sondern von dem Text den der
Schüler unter die Prozentrechnung
geschrieben hat er schrieb nämlich
kleine Anmerkung am Rande man sollte
nicht so viel Platz frei lassen wenn das
jedes Jahr gemacht wird bei fast jeder
Schule und bei jedem Schüler aus dem
achten Jahrgang ist das ganz schöne
Papierverschwendung man könnte dadurch
bestimmt bei einem Schüler ca 7 Blätter
sparen schon alleine in unserer Klasse
wären das um die 196 Blätter nun ein
kleiner Verbesserungsvorschlag und das
war wahrscheinlich Greta tunberg bei der
nächsten lustigen Schüler antworte
sollte ein Schüler schreiben was er
machen möchte wenn er alt ist
und der Schüler antwortet schlafen
for real ich weiß nicht wie ich meine
Schulzeit vor allem auf dem Gymnasium
überlebt habe ne
ich kann euch locker an einer Hand
abzählen
vielleicht zwei Hände ich kann euch an
zwei Händen abzählen
wie oft ich in den sieben Jahren
Gymnasium länger als 8 Stunden
geschlafen habe wo wurde Mozart geboren
da wo seine Mama ihn zur Welt gebracht
hat
ja
ich meine es ist auch wieder richtig mit
welchen Hilfsmitteln kann man ein
Gericht
schmackhafter
gestalten ich weiß nicht aus welchem
Fach das rausgenommen wird ne
ich meine welche Arbeit hat man so eine
Aufgabe egal im Fach Kochen gibt sowas
ganz ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung mit
welchen Hilfsmitteln kann man Gericht
schmackhafter gestalten mir wird da nur
Gewürze einfallen das dachte sich auch
der Schüler der hat das allerdings ein
bisschen falsch geschrieben der hat
nämlich nicht Gewürze sondern Gewürze
geschrieben
[Musik]
dafür kriegst du auf jeden Fall der
Woche hier sollte ein Schüler
beantworten was der geometrische
Fachbegriff dieses Körpers ist und er
schreibt Quader
was logischerweise falsch ist dann wird
er mit Q geschrieben
das K übernimmt alle Sachen die das Kuh
kann nur noch viel mehr
wir brauchen keinen Kuchen wir brauchen
kein Pfau weil wir haben ein K und wir
haben ein F und ich habe einen super
tollen Pops
allerdings auch schon zur letzten
Schülerantworten meine Damen und Herren
ein rechteckiges Grundstück hat eine
Fläche von 450 Quadratmetern
seine Breite beträgt 15 Meter
an einer Längsseite des Grundstücks
fließt ein Bach der Besitzer will zum
Bach hin einen Zaun errichten um Unfälle
zu vermeiden
wie lang muss der Zaun zum Bach hinein
die sollen sich selbst um heraus kümmern
und das ist die richtige
nee es ist eigentlich falsch oder an der
Stelle würde ich das heutige Video jetzt
auch beenden meine Damen und Herren wenn
euch lustige Schülerantworten in Tests
Teil zehn gefallen hat und ihr Bock auf
einen 11 Teil das ist eine Sechs
zehn
elften Teil habt dann lasst einen Daumen
hoch unter dem Video da abonniert meinen
Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke weitere
Videos nicht zu verpassen schreibt immer
unten in die Kommentare welche Brille
ich von den dreien jetzt behalten soll
oder gar keine
Br